[Musica]
di cosa parliamo quando parliamo di
rappresentazione audiovisiva
innanzitutto occorre sottolineare un
aspetto
beh rappresentazione televisiva
audiovisiva innanzitutto è quella
appunto del cinema oppure della tv la
rappresentazione audiovisiva non è la
realtà è quello che si sceglie di
mostrare della realtà e come si sceglie
dimostrarlo
adesso vorrei
chiedervi di immaginare una grande
stanza buia con un singolo angolo e
illuminato
davanti a quel singolo angolo illuminato
cioè una telecamera e davanti
all'obiettivo di quella telecamera
c'è qualcosa di simile al set di una
rivista di design
tutto è di gran gusto tutto è perfetto e
cosa c'è nel buio intorno il disordine
quello che non si vuole fare vedere
questa immagine per raccontarvi che la
rappresentazione audiovisiva quale per
esempio quella delle serie tv di cui un
po parleremo oggi
esiste per rispondere a un bisogno della
società e questo bisogno della società è
fare bella figura
di conseguenza quello che arriverà
davanti all'obiettivo nell'angolo e
illuminato saranno storie che non
pongono un problema alla società di
nessun tipo quindi vedremo tanti come ne
vediamo amori eterosessuali storie di
famiglia vedremo tanti corpi conformi
vedremo tanti corpi bianchi vedremo
tante persone bianche mentre al
contrario
nell'oscurità rimarranno le storie le
persone e le categorie sociali che
sfidano la società che pongono un
problema alla società
perché la società non è in grado di
gestire
l'oppressione sistemica che tocca a
queste persone
a queste categorie
a queste storie
la rappresentazione audiovisiva è potere
ed è un potere è duplice è un potere che
come una medaglia ci sono due facce di
quella medaglia e sono un po in quella
storia della stanza buia con un singolo
angolo e illuminato la rappresentazione
audiovisiva ha il potere di fare vedere
delle cose ma simultaneamente di
inabissare delle altre quindi di
lasciare nel buio delle altre c'è
un'espressione
molto bella è che io uso spesso che è
stata coniata da un massmediologo negli
anni settanta di nome george gardner
george gartner ha parlato delle persone
delle categorie sociali e delle storie
non rappresentate come se fossero
annientate simbolicamente
questo è il grande potere della
rappresentazione audiovisiva la
visibilità versus l'invisibilità zione
quello che si vede esiste quello che si
vede che non si vede non esiste
adesso cominciamo davvero un po a
parlare di serie tv sono sicura che qua
in questa platea ci sono
almeno una buona parte di persone che
guardano abitualmente serie tv e serie
tv sono meravigliose sono il mio
mestiere e fanno parte della nostra
routine fanno parte della nostra vita le
portiamo con noi spesso riempiono i
nostri momenti vuoti spesso le nostre
serate sono davvero sulla bocca di tutte
le persone e per dirvi fino a che punto
sono sulla bocca delle persone vi basta
mi basta darvi dei numeri
sono certa che conoscete una certa
compagnia di nome netflix
netflix nel 2001 cosa che
tutte le persone effettivamente sanno
era molto diverso da quello che oggi
perché era un servizio di noleggio dvd e
contava 400 mila persone abbonate
mutatis mutandis andiamo avanti a oggi
venti anni dopo nel 2021
netflix conta 200
3,66 milioni di persone abbonate in
190 paesi e noi non la conosciamo più
come diciamo servizio di noleggio dvd ma
la conosciamo come celeberrima struttura
produttiva ho detto netflix ma potevo
anche fare un altro esempio credetemi
quindi potevo per esempio parlare disney
plus che è arrivata in italia l'anno
scorso è disponibile in 59 paesi ea 100
milioni di persone abbonate quindi ecco
sono davvero grandi numeri ci
intratteniamo molto con la serialità
televisiva con i film con la
rappresentazione audiovisiva anche se
non lo sappiamo ripassiamo tantissimo
tempo a guardare l'angolo illuminato
della stanza
adesso infatti vorrei parlarvi di una
serie tv che io amo molto e che vi
consiglio di scoprire peraltro se già
non la conoscete la trovate su netflix e
si chiama special è una serie diciamo
speciali di nome e di fatto
perché è un po un unicorno è stata
infatti non solo interpretata ma anche
scritta da questo ragazzo che vedete che
si chiama ryan o'connell brian o'conner
ragazzo gay con paralisi celebrale
dunque è un ragazzo con disabilità che è
riuscito a penetrare nei ranghi di un
sistema molto complesso
raccontando una storia che lo vede
protagonista
purtroppo special è stata cancellata
dopo sole due stagioni di cui una da con
episodio 12 minuti l'una è non è un
grande impegno
e perché vi voglio proprio parlare di
specie al di là del fatto che come vi
dicevo è un unicorno o qualche tempo fa
ho intervistato questo signore qua è
anche qui sono ragionevolmente certa che
qualcuno ha qualche persona qui ha idea
di chi sia
si tratta di jim parsons meglio noto
come lo sheldon cooper di the big bang
theory ma in maniera in realtà
abbastanza distante dal suo personaggio
di the big bang theory jim parsons e
un'attivista per i diritti della
comunità lgbt cui ha più e
è il produttore è uno dei produttori di
special quindi insomma una fu una bella
coincidenza per me ha prodotto special
assieme a suo marito che si chiama top
spin e io gli domandai di special
com'è andata come avete fatto a produrla
perché appunto è una serie abbastanza
differente dalle altre e lui mi rispose
è stato veramente complicato ci abbiamo
messo oltre tre anni perché hollywood a
molti guardiani questa frase è rimasta
molto molto impressa
è ora che vi ho parlato di special
abbiamo parlato della difficoltà di jim
parsons a produrre special vorrei farvi
vedere un
semplice grafico che io ho estrapolato
dal report del club il club è un ente
statistica che si occupa di monitorare
la rappresentazione audiovisiva
soprattutto della comunità lgbt cui ha
più però anche di marginalizzazione la
rappresentazione anche di altre
marginalizzazioni tra cui appunto la
rappresentazione della disabilità
ora ha detto che secondo il center for
disease control
negli stati uniti vivono 61 milioni di
persone con disabilità
il club ha trovato nelle sue analisi
che su oltre 500 serie tv in onda negli
stati uniti in un solo anno
su tutte le piattaforme su tutti i
canali commerciali
la rappresentazione delle persone con
disabilità si aggira intorno al 3,5 per
cento
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che le persone
con disabilità secondo il nostro
ragionamento sono annientate
simbolicamente vuol dire che la
rappresentazione non copre le loro
storie e che queste persone non riescono
a
entrare nelle strutture produttive per
fare arrivare a noi le loro storie qui
vorrei aprire e chiudere molto
velocemente una parentesi e questa è
stata la prima volta di due in cui
utilizzo dei dati relativi agli stati
uniti voi direte ma siamo in italia ma
perché non perché perché marina non usi
delle statistiche italiane invece perché
le statistiche italiane in relazione
alla rappresentazione audiovisiva ma
soprattutto in relazione alle strutture
del potere audiovisivo quindi case di
produzione eccetera queste mappature
probabilmente esistono ma non sono
facilmente accessibili
cioè sicuramente il diversity lab che si
occupa di di rappresentazione
qualitativa ma qui parliamo proprio di
capire a chi si siede in un certo tipo
di posizioni da noi io ho provato a fare
un pò questo esperimento con latte
speaker donata columbro di data ninja
school però è davvero un'impresa onerosa
mi auguro tanto che si riesca a farla
chiusa parentesi torniamo ai nostri
stati uniti dove abbiamo i grafici e
vorrei invitarvi a guardare l'apice
della piramide di questo grafico
parlando di strutture del potere
audiovisivo
come vedete c'è un dato che colpisce
almeno a me colpisce
nella posizione di ceo dunque nella
massima posizione decisionale in
relazione alla rappresentazione
audiovisiva si trovano il
92 per cento di persone
bianche e il 68 per cento di queste
persone sono uomini
il che vuol dire che di fatto la
rappresentazione audiovisiva questo
grande potere è nelle mani di una
singola categoria sociale gli uomini
bianchi
io sono sicura questi 68 per cento di
uomini bianchi ci sono delle persone
straordinarie punto non è questo il
punto
è l'unica storia
il punto è che alle sulle sedie del
potere
si siedono pochissime donne
e a proposito di donne di sede del
potere e di storie
con me vi è stato anticipato
io mi occupo molto di viaggio
dell'eroina il viaggio dell'eroina è una
variante rispetto al viaggio dell'eroe
ma è una ingombrante variante solo che è
pochissimo studiata perché si parla
sempre invece di viaggio eroico come di
viaggio eroico maschile e diciamo si
sostiene che siano in realtà che si è la
stessa cosa che il viaggio dell'eroe la
struttura in tre atti con cui vengono
costruite la stragrande maggior parte
delle storie che noi fruiamo si sostiene
che sia unisex quando in realtà non lo è
vi voglio dire che il viaggio dell'eroe
discende in particolare da un libro che
è l'eroe dai mille volti del professor
joseph campbell mentre il viaggio
dell'eroina
discende più o meno invece da maureen
murdoch un'autrice che seguiva i
seminari di joseph campbell allora un
giorno morin murdoch andò da joseph
campbell e li chiese professore è tutto
meraviglioso terribilmente affascinante
ma che può per favore spiegare perché
siccome voi parlate sempre di eroe
cosa succede alla donna se la donna alla
protagonista di una storia
e il nostro amico joseph campbell
rispose alla nostra amica amore in
murdoch
la donna non è viaggiatrice la donna è
meta
questo è il potere delle storie e il
potere delle storie tracima nella
rappresentazione audiovisiva quindi per
tanto tempo e ancora oggi le donne sono
considerate
mete non viaggiatrici e tra l'altro cosa
che mi fa insomma ancora più specie
si parla sempre di le donne le donne
come se fossimo avete presente le
caramelle che si prendono con la paletta
nel negozio tutti della stessa forma
tutte con lo stesso sapore tutte magari
con lo zucchero sopra ma noi siamo tutte
diverse noi abbiamo tutte esperienze
diverse noi abbiamo corte conformi corpi
non conformi siamo grasse
siamo di seconda generazione
siamo lesbiche siamo pansessuali
bisessuali
vogliamo dei figli non li vogliamo
non ci sono
ci sono due donne che abbiano la stessa
storia
infatti il problema qui non è soltanto
cosa si trova davanti all'obiettivo
della telecamera nel singolo angolo e
illuminato della stanza il problema è
anche chi sta dietro la telecamera
chi è che racconta quelle storie sono
sempre le stesse persone
è possibile
ci manda a ngozi adichie
favolosa ten speaker nel suo the talk il
pericolo di un unica storia ha detto il
potere la possibilità non solo di
raccontare la storia di un'altra persona
ma di farla diventare la storia
definitiva di quella persona
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che certo
quando parliamo di storytelling valle
tutto però se si parla di identità e se
si parla di esperienza socio culturale
del proprio corpo nella realtà allora se
io che sono una donna cis cioè io sono
una donna che si identifica con il sesso
che le è stato assegnato alla nascita se
io scrivo la storia di una donna trans
ok e quindi la storia di quella donna
trans finisce nell'angolo illuminato
della stanza io non ho idea di che cosa
voglia dire fare l'esperienza di quel
corpo avere quelle sensazioni
essere vivere quella vita
perché il punto è anche questo ripeto
quello storytelling vale tutto non c'è
dubbio non si sa ancorati alla realtà
non abbiamo i pesi ai piedi per cui
dobbiamo solo parlare di realtà ma la
nostra esperienza
personale l'esperienza che noi facciamo
con le nostre identità in forma anche la
fantasia
in maniera imprevedibile e meravigliose
e la base della pluralità che si auspica
per l'industria audiovisiva e per la
serialità televisiva ed è per questo che
io dico
dobbiamo restituire le storie alle
persone rappresentate
ma come fare come fare non ci sono poche
storie per esempio di donne nere ma
tantissime sono scritte da persone
bianche non ci sono poche storie di
donne ma tantissime nella stragrande
ente che non va ma nella maggioranza
sono scritti da uomini come si fa a
sfondare quel muro come si fa a
oltrepassare quel confine
io credo che sia necessario qualcosa di
più dell'affidarsi semplicemente al buon
cuore o alle opportunità che cascano in
grembo di volta in volta di quella
struttura o di un'altra
io credo che siano necessari degli aiuti
solidi anche dalla parte da parte della
politica da parte degli stati per far sì
che persone con esperienze differenti si
avvicinano all industria audiovisiva e
quando si parla di industria audiovisiva
di cosa si parla si parla di scuole di
recitazione si parla di squallidi regia
di direzione della fotografia si parla
di scuola di sceneggiatura tutto questo
le persone che non sono rappresentate le
persone che sono annientate
simbolicamente finiscono inevitabilmente
per auto squalificarsi perché
percepiscono che non c'è posto per loro
lì e che cosa succede dunque perché
continuiamo a vedere un unica storia
ora va meglio che in passato per carità
ma la strada è davvero davvero lunga e
io sono convinta che non si è più tempo
di aggirare i guardiani di jim parsons
di soppiatto credo che sia arrivato il
momento
espugnare la fortezza con un grido
[Applauso]
[Musica]